[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a zombie comedy film called fido
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in an alternate universe a cloud of
radiation coming from outer space has
engulfed the earth the radiation caused
the buried dead bodies to re-animate and
attack humans as flesh-eating zombies
soon the earth was flush with such
creatures who started killing everyone
that came in their way mankind
retaliated and a zombie war began
humans had a hard time winning the war
until their savior dr reinhold geiger
established an organization called the
zomcom the doctor discovered that if the
brain of a zombie was destroyed the
zombie would die never to reanimate
again
using this information the soldiers
fighting the zombies aimed for their
brains and soon the war was won what
were they aiming for before
zomcon built a security system to save
their town from further zombie attacks
they built a perimeter fence that
enclosed the town to not allow the
zombies to enter but even within the
fence when people die they would turn
into zombies because of the radiation
people's lives were at great risk but dr
reinhold geiger came through with a
great invention called the domestication
collar with this collar the zombie's
flesh cravings would die down making
them docile a red light from the caller
suggests that the zombie's desire for
the flesh has been contained
people were suggested to call zomcon or
push the nearest safety button if the
light from the caller goes out when the
zombies became docile people started
using them as maids and butlers to help
them with household work
those who did not wish to live like
zombies and could afford a funeral were
buried deep inside the ground after
their heads were cut off from their
bodies also known as the reanimation
free burial in the town of willard
children in school are taught about
zomcon and the history of zombies in one
such class the head of security at
zomcon jonathan bottoms visits the
students mr bottoms daughter cindy is
also a student in the class
mr bottoms boasts about him making the
town's safety against the zombies
tighter making the students clap in
appreciation but a kid named timmy
robinson doesn't seem impressed he asks
mr bottoms what would happen if the
zombies who were buried come out someday
he thinks that they might have been
crawling their way up little by little
mr bottoms is left speechless and the
teacher soon ends the class the kids are
also taught to use a rifle in willard to
prepare them for any kind of zombie
attack two of timmy's friends bully him
and are sent for detention when he comes
back home timmy sees that the barros
family is moving into their neighborhood
timmy's mother helen welcomes him home
and dismisses him and he talks about his
bullies later at night his father bill
returns from work and sees helen has
prepared a plethora of dishes for him it
turns out that she had bought a zombie
to help her around the house bill is not
thrilled about the new purchase because
he is scared of zombies but helen
insists that their new neighbors have
six zombies and they should have at
least one
bill controls the creature through a
remote and hurts him in the process
little timmy pities the zombie and asks
his father to stop the following day
timmy waits for bill to play catch with
him but bill makes an excuse and goes
out to play golf with his friends
timmy's parents are nonchalant about
their duty towards their child his needs
are often ignored in his home he goes
outside to play alone but helen asks him
to stop because she doesn't want the
neighbors to think he is lonely timmy
then goes to the park and sees a zombie
trying to fetch a can from the ground
someone is controlling the can from the
bushes and troubling the zombie timmy
goes to the bushes and sees that his
bullies are responsible for the prank
the bullies push him to the ground and
are about to shoot him when timmy's new
zombie comes to his aid he pushes the
bullies away and saves him a happy timmy
thanks the zombie and names him fido
then the two try to play catch but fido
doesn't know how so instead timmy plays
fetch with fido treating him like his
pet dog as they play the ball lands near
timmy's aggressive old neighbor mrs
henderson when fido goes to pick it up
the old woman attacks him and hits him
repeatedly making his caller
dysfunctional
fido turns into a flesh-eating zombie
again and kills mrs henderson just then
timmy arrives at the scene and is
horrified to see him feeding on mrs
henderson fido makes his way towards
timmy but suddenly his caller starts
working again timmy takes him back home
but they forget to take the ball with
them
fido and timmy are now in bill's garage
where timmy cleans him he notices a
surgery mark on fido's chest and figures
that he died from a heart attack helen
walks in and asks him what they are
doing timmy tries to tell her about mrs
henderson but helen doesn't give him a
chance to talk at breakfast the next day
timmy mentions that fido died from a
heart attack like bill's father which
upsets bill he had to kill his own
father during the zombie war
then mr bottoms comes over to timmy's to
socialize and talk about mrs henderson's
sudden disappearance it turns out that
the police have started looking for her
timmy listens to their conversation
after the guests leave he asks his
parents about mrs henderson helen tells
him that if a pet zombie has attacked
mrs henderson his masters would be
thrown to the danger zone outside the
town at night mrs henderson turns into a
zombie and walks around the town she
attacks a man turning him into a zombie
as well timmy is scared of being thrown
into the danger zone so he goes out
looking for mrs henderson's dead body to
hide it but he only finds her
decapitated arm
suddenly the zombie mrs henderson
attacks timmy but he manages to hit her
with a shovel after hitting her
repeatedly he decapitates her and then
buries her in a public garden
fido is kept tied to a tree outside at
night timmy sees him struggling and
making a lot of noise when he goes to
check on him he finds that the light in
the collar is off which means that it
isn't working the noise wakes one of
timmy's neighbors called theopolis he
offers to help timmy with the zombie
problem the two bring fido to mr
theopolis's house where he fixes his
collar they agree not to tell anyone of
the incident because a dysfunctioning
caller should be reported to the zomcon
the next day helen gets fido dressed up
in bill's suit to take him to a funeral
she has started liking fido bill is
obsessed with zombie funerals and
attends one whenever he can the four
attend the funeral where the zombie's
body and head are put into two different
coffins meanwhile the zombie that mrs
henderson had bitten attacks other
people in the park the town is now
infested with zombies
the zomcon workers fight them and try to
bring the situation under control the
following day helen sees timmy playing
with fido and is happy to see he has
finally found a friend she brings juice
for both bill complains saying that the
zombie doesn't need to eat or drink but
helen insists that he can
she asks bill to stay home and enjoy
time with family but he drives away with
his friend while leaving he turns around
to see fido helen and timmy playing like
a happy family
one day timmy's bullies are caught by mr
bottoms for accidentally shooting a
zomcon worker's leg mr bottoms suspects
that the kids shot mrs henderson and
killed her who in turn is creating more
zombies but the kids pushed the blame
upon timmy and fido saying that fido
attacked them at the park earlier then
we see fido and timmy climbing up a hill
while talking about how they're always
going to be together suddenly they are
attacked by the bullies again who tie
them to a tree their plan is to destroy
the caller and then kill fido so
everyone would think they are the town's
heroes they break his collar but are too
scared to shoot him but one of them gets
shot instead
fido frees himself and chases the bully
into a small cabin nearby
there he eats him he then approaches
timmy but doesn't attack him fido has
built an emotional connection with timmy
even greater than his hunger for flesh
when he cannot untie timmy himself fido
goes to search for help and brings back
helen a bully has turned into a zombie
and is about to attack timmy but fido
and helen reach just in time to stop him
helen burns the little cabin to get rid
of the evidence
later the robinsons are at mr bottom's
home helen talks to bottoms wife dee
about her being pregnant mr bottoms has
been noticing helen being friendly to
fido and warns bill about the situation
he suspects fido to be mrs henderson's
killer when they come back home bill
tries talking to helen but is dismissed
meanwhile the zomcon workers find mrs
henderson's body and the ball timmy had
left at the site they traced the murder
back to fido and arrest him the
following day a saddened timmy chases
the van fydo is in but is stopped by mr
bottoms after a few days mr bottoms
daughter cindy tells timmy that fido is
still alive she had heard mr bottoms
talking to someone on the phone about
not wasting a good zombie
fido is being made to work in a zomcon
factory as free labor they ask for their
neighbor mr theopolis's help to get into
the factory and rescue fido mr theopolis
used to be a worker at zomcon but was
fired for being in a romantic
relationship with a zombie he and timmy
go to the zomcon headquarters where
people go to repair their old zombies mr
theopolis breaks a zombie's collar and
creates havoc in the establishment now
they just have to go to the factory on
the other side and bring fido back
meanwhile helen and bill find out about
timmy's plan and make their way to the
zomcon headquarters as well timmy
manages to get inside the factory while
mr theopolis fights the receptionist but
mr bottoms sees that timmy has snuck in
through the surveillance camera mr
bottoms finds timmy and throws him to
the other side of the fence that
protects the town several wild zombies
make their way towards the kid as he
yells for help just then fido and billy
arrive and ask mr bottoms to let timmy
in bill and mr bottoms get into an
intense fight and timmy manages to get
inside the fence again he points a rifle
at mr bottoms and asks for his father to
be let free
but mr bottoms accidentally shoots bill
dead
timmy then breaks fido's caller and
makes him attack mr bottoms fido finally
kills bottoms and saves timmy some time
later helen organizes a funeral for bill
fido has been freed from imprisonment
and lives with helen timmy and helen's
newborn child mr bottoms has turned into
a zombie and is controlled by his
daughter cindy the movie ends as fido
lovingly caresses the newborn baby
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching